[PIANO]
Data is transforming business,
social interactions, and the
future of our society.
Analytics is at the heart of
the companies of our times,
like Google, Amazon, and IBM.
In this course, you will learn
how to use analytics and data
to give an edge to your
career and your life.
Together, we'll explore a wide
variety of inspiring examples,
like the meaning of
intelligence, what predicts
happiness, and how
data is changing
the future of medicine.
I'm Dimitris Bertisimas.
And I've been a professor
at MIT since 1988.
My career has focused
around analytics.
And I believe analytics
can positively
influence the world.
And I'm Allison O'Hair.
I received my Ph.D.
from MIT in 2013.
Together, in 15.071x, the
Analytics Edge, we'll dive
into some of the most exciting
examples and techniques in
this field.
In February 2011, the world
watched in awe as a computer
beat the best human players
at Jeopardy, a game that
showcases human intelligence.
You will learn how this
remarkable feat was
accomplished and why the same
computer is now being used to
design cancer treatments.
We'll discuss the story of
Moneyball and how the Oakland
A's surprised the world by
taking a very small budget and
creating a championship
baseball team.
We will also feature how the
online dating site eHarmony is
using data and optimization to
predict compatibility and to
find, , among millions of
people, a perfect match.
The only prerequisites for
this class are basic
mathematics and an excitement
about learning analytics.
In each lecture and homework
assignment, we'll start with a
story and a real data set and
then teach you the method that
was used in that application.
You will learn specific methods,
work with data, and
see how analytics provided
an edge to real
people and real companies.
Join our whole team here at
MIT to learn the analytics
edge that you can give to your
career and your life.